the russian ministry of defence says
this destroyed building was a ukrainian
weapons factory in the southwest
outskirts of the capital kiev
moscow says the plant made anti-aircraft
and anti-ship missiles people living
nearby say they heard at least three
large explosions early friday morning
we parked the car and the two rockets
hit at 1am i did not realize that there
are two rockets coming in but when i
went out afterwards i waited indoors for
some time fearing more shelling we saw
the third one coming it damaged the car
tore out the tires hit the windows and
walls people suffered too the walls fell
the out came hours after russia said its
black sea fleet flagship the mosque bar
had sunk while being towed back to port
after a fire caused an explosion on
board
ukrainian military said it was
responsible having targeted the vessel
with ukrainian-made neptune missiles
people gathered at a memorial ceremony
for the ship in the port city of
sevastopol in russian annexed crimea
the moskva was the largest russian naval
vessel to have sunk in action since
world war ii
even for those who have not been there
moskva was a symbol for everyone symbol
of our power our hope the revival of the
fleet in the 90s it is a symbol of
engineering and scientific achievements
force of our arms
the ukrainian army says it repelled
russian army advances on at least two
towns in the east of the country
russia has redirected its forces from
kiev in an effort to seize more
territory in the donbass region
volunteers help ukrainian soldiers pack
food to be distributed to some of the
many thousands of people fleeing all
those still living in the worst affected
areas i stay here because it's my home
and we help people delivering food
chemistry
and
our
town
just destroying
oh it's not good
i don't know what to say
okay i want to move
okay this drone footage shows destroyed
residential buildings in mariopol
the besieged port city on the azov sea
has suffered seven weeks of bombardment
by russian forces and pro-russian
separatists
repeated attempts at securing
humanitarian corridors to rescue
thousands of people trapped inside have
failed
the mayor of the city estimates
thousands of civilians may have been
killed in the fighting
ukraine's ministry of defense says
russia has for the first time used
long-range bombers to attack the city
russian occupants keep carrying out
aerial strikes on mariopol they use
long-range bombers the enemy's land
forces are trying to capture the seaport
the strike on what the russian defense
ministry describes as a weapons factory
on the outskirts of kiev is the first
major strike by russian forces on a
target around the capital city
since russian forces left the area more
than two weeks ago
major military operations now for the
time being have moved east where there
are increasing reports of an effort by
the russian military to close in
around the strategically important city
of slavyansk
the un says that more than 4.7 million
people have fled the fighting and with
no
indication of any de-escalation that
number is expected to rise charles
stratford al jazeera kiev